In this section, we will delve into fitting metahuman topology to scan in sculpted meshes.
One approach is to use the metahuman presets for fitting metahuman topology to a target
delta.
And another approach is to use the standard mesh to metahuman workflow to generate an
identity.
We will first explore using metahuman presets for fitting and how the metahuman identity
texture can be a helpful reference for the fitting process.
The goal of fitting is to first wrap metahuman topology to a scanner sculpt as this will
be the target delta.
From there, that asset can be used with the mesh to metahuman workflow using the template
mesh option to generate a metahuman identity whose geometry and joints are closer to the
target delta.
Begin by going to the metahuman creator and selecting a preset.
Then download the metahuman source assets from the Quixel Bridge standalone application
and using the LOD0 head mesh from the Maya scene, fit it to the model.
The metahuman identity texture can be used as a reference during the fitting process.
When fitting important polygon flow transitions, the metahuman identity texture can be a helpful
reference.
It can be found inside of Unreal Engine by going to all, plugins, metahuman content,
identity template.
In the material named metahuman identity head, you can locate the texture there and export
it.
Some important polygon flow transition regions include the eyes, particularly the inner edge
of the eyelid.
For the mouth area, pay close attention to the inner and outer vermilion and the contact
edge of the lips, as well as the transition regions of the nose bridge and middle of the
neck.
Now that we have a better idea of how we can approach fitting metahuman topology using
metahuman presets, in the next section we will review some important terminology that
relates to metahuman identity conforming before delving into fitting metahuman topology using
the mesh to metahuman workflow.